all right here we go
team white
get this over here
yeah this ticker didn't show up in those
created tournaments
secure that pawn
stop b5
knight here is probably good
i should have prevented that
bishop here
maybe
okay let's stop knight here all together
i'm on d6 twice bishop has to go back
let's just secure that point knight here
will add another attacker on this
um
let's just take once
attack that knight
what
okay
i'm getting this
secure my night position i don't think
that pond's going anywhere
okay this is a nice home for my king on
h2
definitely take that he's passed now
he's not going anywhere
let's just go here
the rook is really active
my knight is way too good here
it's a really really strong piece i had
a fork
um
i want to get on this diagonal maybe
let's come back over here and then queen
here
take here and then there's stuff
happening on the queen
um
where's the mate
let's check
check
no mates
let my king sneak out
they're down on time wow why did i think
i was down on time
oh
okay
a lot of people up there with
oh two games in already
okay
double the cube
sicilian stuff again
yes
queen c7 knight c6
okay
queenside castle
what's it going to be yes
on the bishop in h2
bishop here
h
2
12
6
and a bunch of sixes
h2 strikes
again
all right
let's try knight f3
get king side fiend keto
look for a break with d5 maybe
now bishop here
that pawn can maybe be taken and hung
onto he's supported now with my knight
queen opposite the king
keep the structure as is
maybe knight here would threaten a fork
on d2
let's get here maybe something with f3
oh i think i had a sack i had um a fork
here take here and then take a bunch of
times on d5 and i get this piece
i sure went for that
can i still do it and i'd give up two
minor pieces for the rook in that case
they didn't see my knight was on that
threading a fork on e6
massive fork happening
ouch it's a royal fork right there
there goes the queen
28 seconds each
um
20 seconds
the wolf
the wolf resigned back to tournament 12.
okay
how are we doing there's 73 players in
here
here's a big one c5 decline it
try for h2 i'll never fall for that
right
hang on i'm still going for it i think
this is something i covered in the
fishing pole video
bishop to
okay they're giving the material back
queen is crawling into a ball
light square issues
hmm i really shouldn't have done that
gonna take
oh
missed that
queen to d7 and then get to h3
let's kick that queen away
threatening me on each one
queen trade
the knight
got to be careful
right here
on f3 and the knight
how are we doing with the time
rook here was maybe better
no mates
i got this square covered
one accurate move think i have it
why'd i go for this line
oh i could have done better
i think this is still a win though
yeah it's still a win
i don't have any time back to tournament
oh
man
i had something better there
i mean i know i missed something with
that knight being a pin
should not have come down to a king and
pawn ending oh take a free knight
please take three nights
i was in pre-move mode sort of
all right let's try this i'm gonna play
here
and work on these light squares no not
so fast let's just defend that pun
upon push maybe next
queen here if i need some support and
then i'll queenside castle
let's pin the knight
retake with my knight or queen
i want to keep the position open
yeah
definitely
oh he's in a pin still
he's attacked too
hmm
okay
trade down i'm okay with trading
he's throwing a check
play here
forks
queen trade and then take the knight
okay
defend the second rank i'm on that
square
get to the seventh back to term and 30s
oh man i think i'm still winded from
that last tournament
22
minutes remain
all right d4 d5
let's try c5 knight c6 queen b6 pressure
and
let's see if i can get out here before
e6
okay i'm happy with this structure
good versus bad bishop situations are
still available
and
even in bullet
even in these uh positional type of
games
good thing to have
okay castle
i think i want to take with my pawn yeah
right here is going to fall with tempo
all right let's take here
and then push get rid of
their central pawn two to zero majority
in the center
how are they going to recapture queen
this tempo
another tempo
queen here can't make use of b8
okay
queen e5 if pawn takes
this is a very good home for the queen
and my rook is super active
flight square for my
king rook here
maybe plant my pawn up here kind of
restricts all the pawns
i can also think about f5
i can have a queen trade queen here
check
um how do i win this
okay slow and steady
i have a time edge
pressure here defend this pawn and then
my f-pawn could get working
my king gets to
f5 and then i'm
having this move supported
not so easy gotta try a different
direction
oh i just dropped a pawn
okay here we go
this is just not gonna even end
keep pressure on that pawn
got that pawn with check
drop back here
get another pawn they don't have any
time back to term at 42
49 42
42 42
double
double those points
and they're going with the hippopotamus
something like that oh no no
i'm gonna go queenside they're probably
gonna queenside castle
let's play here
uh let's throw in a check
i guess
get my other rook working pawn push will
gain attempt oh i'm gonna have a nice
home now
for a piece here their bishop is kind of
dead for as long as i can control d4
am i going to get here he's a bit of a
pain
for sure
let's make sure i could get rid of him
i spent a lot of time right there
um let's give the queen a kick
clean check
they might miss it
lateral movement of the queen no i have
a fork here
i got a pawn 20 seconds to 40 seconds
my knight's defending b2
and this the light squares are defended
quite nicely
uh let's do this my knight's going to
get kicked
i have all my base points covered except
for h2
forks are in the air
let's get my king on the dark square the
bishop is kind of dead now
let's go back here
fork
um
okay i'm gonna track that pawn down now
here no matter what
9.6
make sure i could get rid of that pawn
i'm just going to go over here
go fast
go really fast
i have a time edge right now
you're down on time back to tournaments
oh man 63 56
chess
just skype
okay
um
okay that weakens this diagonal
i get d5 in now
this is a very good uh
oops
very good break
get their dark square bishop
and i just want to push ooh knight here
let's take him out
i was ready to move my knight
let's do this knight here although i
want to keep the queens on the board in
this case
seeing a lot of potential for
knight here hitting the queen and
smashing through on this square
hmm queen here
maybe
let's get rid of that bishop
take the knight maybe in some lines
queen here i take the knight
his pawns pinned it's back on this is
difficult to defend
smashing through on this square now
on the queen
and here
let's take them with check and probably
this next
um let's throw another check in i want
to take this pawn with check okay that's
better
mate next move they resigned back to
tournament 90 72 i was fearful of a
queen check on that diagonal
that's why i didn't want to i think take
with the rook i wanted to take pieces
with check
it took me so long to move right there
this guy's not moving he is moving now
knight c3 and e4 nimzo indian
yes classical
all right
maybe we should have challenged that
bishop right away this can't be bad
though right
that bishop's wasting a lot of time
without being provoked he went back
there then i can't play here i'm going
to gain another tempo
hitting at h7
i think i just want to clarify this
structure i am helping the light square
bishop i want to maintain my knight here
i have a majority on the king's side i
think best was c5 and then knight c6
need to keep pressure on my position
c5 now
now these these pawns get rolling and i
could take here on c5
he's ready to get pushed away
c5 needed to be played with the
majorities and how they've shifted four
to three on the king side now we have f6
it's getting blown right open
even at the cost of a pond but it's not
the cost of upon it's just really
big trouble now
okay let's take some material first
take here and then just get some trades
and i want my queen to be able to
breathe here
exchange light square bishops and then
she has new options
get my knight back to f3
oh they're really low on time
here no matter what no if yeah that's
that would be okay
queen f2
they don't have any time
what's happening they have to check the
server now back to tournament
90 90 490s are up there
polyphase
all right
check bononi it is
all right we're going to try oh
really
whoa i wasn't expecting f5 i wasn't
expecting f4
let's do this
okay i'm getting a pawn here
my other knight working
go queen side
my pawn on h4 is very annoying
it's got to be very annoying
and let's let's open up the h file if
they take my rook is brought right to
life
he has to move and there's mating ideas
here
i don't want a queen trade in this
position looking for something more
hit the queen
um
i mean i could go for a queen trade here
let's check
getting a ton of material
i'm on the bishop that's a fork
31 seconds
the knight is stuck he can maybe only go
here they resign back to tournament
117 110 110 13 minutes remain
i'm exhausted
i am exhausted
wow
okay
queen b3
let's back up give me the h file maybe
queen b6 i do this
okay
probably should have taken there but
let's just castle
and where is there an advantage if at
all
not much of an advantage
throw my um i shouldn't allow that
should just taken okay i'll take with
the rook i think
i want to get an f3 e4 kill the bishop
okay actually i could have a ton of
exchanges
why though i'm waiting upon now with
that continuation
um
i should have just taken the pun that
bishop was stupid i wasn't doing
anything
knight takes pawn there no
not sure why knight takes pawn 19
seconds
take that pawn
take my bishop
definitely welcome that
take this pawn he's fast
he's really fast
get rid of one rook oh now now i'm going
to be pushing through right here
mates right on h4
back on h4 mate threat
that's me
back to tournament 130 130.
we both have 11 games in and there's 11
minutes remaining
okay
let's keep rolling here let's try king's
indian
all
right let's get an e5
and then look for e4 or maybe a fork
not quite on
oh that weakens this dark square
eliminate him and jump into white's
territory
could exchange queens
and we're going to have what
this is a typical maneuver
reinforce my control over this square
get my knight in here
hmm
where's that night going
here to blockade
okay now he's kind of stuck how does he
get to this square
my knight is really good on e5
that's a free pawn pawn push my rook is
hit
just move out of the way to though to c8
okay
24 seconds
tempo and then probably just get pushing
oh i'm on the queen
24
seconds
they resigned back to tournament one
fifty one thirty seven one thirty ten
minutes remain
okay
i can try this h h-pawn
not so fast
not so fast all right let me get this
tempo here
queen on h6
each file is opened up
wow
night here
checkmate
pawn takes and then mate
back to tournament 171.37 that was a
quick one
oh man
all right
let's keep going here
i have a lead let's try to keep it here
break down this structure
takes you can't take back because of
knight takes a1
okay let's take care make sure i get
that pawn
i really want to just give up my rook
here just to focus on these dark squares
and get castled soon
maybe i shouldn't have castled so soon
on push get my center i have a
two-to-one majority in the center let's
get that working
not just yet i don't give up this square
i'll take like this
and the night i need a flight square
okay now let's definitely pin the knight
knight here to defend
keep the pin
catching up on time
flight square
keep the rooks on the board if rook to
e1
let's try this
oh now here i could have considered
i want to
have to be careful back rank because
this flight square is taken away from me
now
they're spending a lot of time here
real lot of time
queen b1
let's just trade a little bit five
seconds
anything moves queen h2 moves
anything moves they don't have any time
back to tournament 190 157 150 148
seven minutes remain
e4
and we're gonna have a french
okay
let's try
this
okay and h4 give me the h file
okay
this i get into d6 with check unless you
castle and if you castle then there's
going to be some problems i think
it's a problem no matter how you look at
it and actually i could take here and
then take the bishop
okay
and how could i
win this
in a smooth way they resigned back to
tournament 210 170. i have two games up
mr cube fanatic has 13 out of 13. he's
perfect
um
all right let's focus on these dark
squares
hmm winning a pawn here
all right
let's just return
yeah why not i'm hitting this pawn but i
don't really want to take it i didn't
want to do that either i wasted a ton of
time just then
hit the bishop and defend c7
dark squares are super weak now
and bound to be even more weak after i
eliminate my light square bishop for
this guy
he defended b2 and got out of a pin
there
let's just take him out
and
develop with check
you play this
okay make sure this pawn doesn't move
opposite color bishop ending but i have
play against this guy here
a6 and then b5
for some tactics maybe to take on this
square maybe push now actually
like right now oh rook back fortunately
he's in a pin i didn't see that
did not see that couple pins going on
here
queen is super active and he's ready to
be pushed
i like pushing here i could have done
this should have done one move sooner
attack that pinned piece
i don't have to take it right away
but i will
definitely well
some trades get my rook on the second
rank
second rank and then push again
keep pushing
and
do what next
they're going to lose on time here
just take that bishop out
take here
they're down on time back to tournament
230
171.68 less than five minutes remain
okay
we're gonna get paired up
430 remain
rob
5-2-1
is he going to move
yes he is okay
he resigned
back to tournament that basically
already seals it or does it i'm up 60
now
four minutes
here no matter what doesn't matter what
that next move is by white
bishop g7
let's play over here with this b5 push
there's maybe a way to gain a tempo
against their dark sky bishop he is a
bit loose
maybe bishop to e6
oh
now bishop to e6
my knight wants to get here
knight b6 c4 queen b6 if the f-pawn
moves
f-pawn can't move so easily
i should have played here while it was
still available
oh boy no my knight gets this really
good square
if this pawn pushes it's a really really
good square
um
i'm not moving
i am not moving
my knight likes to play here instead i
think my queen might want to play to
this square
let me get rid of their knight
knight's gonna play here no i gotta pass
pawn and my queen cannot be removed she
is
to the e5 square
and she's trying to be removed
okay let's do this now my knight is
going to be glued here
they do have a pass pawn
they're in a pin if the bishop takes
self pin
they saw it they sniffed that one out
they thought something was fishy and
they are right
definitely right
good eye
good eye 8.3 seconds
i gotta go fast
i have to go faster no no no no no
check
here check here check
here no matter what
maybe that's mate maybe it's not
i gained a lot of time just then my
knight can't move he's pinned back to
tournament they're down on time 270 220
205 198
two minutes remain
okay
see a lot of this d4 c5 stuff
wow those were two very quick moves
right there
oh i'm glad that was check
otherwise i would have dropped a beast
what are they doing with their dark
squares bishop to h6 right if that
knight moves chase him out of there look
to e1
sometime lost right there
hit the queen she has to find a new home
she's not going anywhere it's covered
the rook is hit
discovered checks i probably back
determined they resigned i should have
played bishop to b5 check 122
see if i could get one more in
game 20
last one
most
likely i didn't mean to do c6
e5 e4
let's try this
sack
all right long-term idea behind that one
back rankers maybe
i want to get the move back i'm taking
with the pawn
bishop on d5
maybe i should have prevented b4 i don't
want to castle i like my rook where he
is
let's try this
on push
bishop on f6
let's open up the g file
let's check
oh this is getting broken down now
i have really quick access to their king
now
making one threat queen g2
anything ah
first place oh they didn't like how they
blew the whistle on that first place
confetti oh
i'm exhausted
oh and there's another tournament coming
up after this one good games ah
it's you 92 245 240 206.
man play here
counter pin
oh i could take the queen oh there goes
my queen
oh man those lateral movements with the
queen at least i get a rook somehow is
this going to be good